seulement deux jours après l annonce du
déconfinement en allemagne un canton du
nord-ouest décide de faire demi tour et
de prolonger les mesures sanitaires
en cause une usine où plus de 100
employés sur 1200 été infectées dans les
stalles mans plusieurs maisons de
retraite connaissent une augmentation du
nombre de cas pour moi ce déconfinement
va trop vite
on aurait dû encore attendre deux ou
trois semaines
et pour ouvrir normalement sans que tous
n'ont ils doivent porter un masque pour
éviter une nouvelle vague l'exécutif
allemand a donc opté pour un repos
finement à l'échelle locale situation
sensiblement similaires en espagne avec
un déconfinement très progressive dans
le pays
barcelone et madrid où le virus circule
encore sont exclues du dispositif de
retour à la normale bars et restaurants
sont notamment privé de réouverture pour
les autres villes du pays
le premier ministre appelle à la
prudence à partir de ce lundi 6 date à
laquelle l'espagne débute son processus
d'assouplissement des mesures je tiens à
souligner une fois de plus que le virus
n'a pas disparu il est toujours là à
l'affût la lutte contre l'épidémie se
poursuit car elle n'a pas été éteintes
et ne le sera pas tant que nous n'aurons
pas trouvé un vaccin ou un rom est
thérapeutique définitive au japon l'île
d'hokkaido c'est totalement raviser
déconfit né le 19 mars dernier les
habitants de nouveau été mis à
l'isolément le 12 avril après
l'apparition une seconde vague
épidémique en chine plusieurs endroits
ont été remis en quarantaine après la
découverte de nouvelles contaminations
c'est le cas notamment de la ville de
schumann ou aux personnes infectées
auraient été recensés ce week-end pour
éviter une reprise de l'épidémie si la
tendance s'oriente donc vers un nouveau
confinement dans certaines régions du
monde
dans un contexte où la majorité des pays
se prépare à assouplir leur mesure